ثم اليوم لا توجد طريقة
حلول
هذه المشكلة التي ، اذا حكمنا من قبل
ضاغط محطة تورتوجا
[موسيقى]
بالطبع سيتم تركيب التوربين هناك
نعلم أن لدينا أيضًا خيامًا
وحدات أخرى
حول أي شركة 7 تدرك جيدًا أيضًا ، ولكن
بطبيعة الحال سيتم تركيب التوربين
بعد الانتهاء من جميع الإجراءات الشكلية
عملية الجرار و
سيذهب الضخ في الحجم الذي
التقنيات الممكنة
[موسيقى]
المغفرة مهتمة
روسيا مخلص مسؤول
الغاز والذين لن يتحدثوا
المفوضية الأوروبية العواصم الروسية بينيون
أن روسيا كانت ولا تزال
البلد الذي ينبغي إلى حد كبير
يضمن أمن الطاقة
ليس بشكل معلن بل بحكم الأمر الواقع
[موسيقى]
الآن نسمع كل أنواع الحقيقة
أفكار للحد
حجم الروسي لن يحد من كل شيء
النفط الروسي هو كل نفس
يحدث تظهر النتيجة حتى
إنه لأمر مدهش ما يقوله الناس
تعليم عالى
ستكون النتيجة نفس المصعد مع و
ارتفعت أسعار النفط بشكل كبير